breaking news the Prime Minister we are
being told in the last few moments has
arrived back in Downing Street we know
he's been convalescing in checkers
following his brush with coronavirus he
left hospital two weeks ago we know he's
due back at work on Monday but he has
now arrived back in Downing Street
before any further ado let's bring in
our chief political correspondent John
Craig who's in Westminster for us now
this news breaking in the last few
moments John just happened a couple of
minutes ago yes I think the Prime
Minister would probably argue it was a
bit more than a brush with the
coronavirus he was in hospital for a
week and three of those seven nights he
was in intensive care and it's exactly
two weeks since he left hospital on
Easter Sunday he came back from Thomas's
hospital then went into number ten
recorded a video in which he thanked NHS
staff for saving his life so clearly it
was very serious illness he spent the
last two weeks at Chequers but we
learned yesterday that he was due to
come back to work tomorrow and he has
taken the short drive from
Buckinghamshire to Downing Street just
arrived by the back entrance no pictures
of him getting outside the out of the
car by the famous black front door but
he's back in Downing Street just arrived
now number 10 of course have told us
that he is raring to go he's going to
get back to his usual schedule we
understand that over the course of the
next 24 hours he's going to be having a
series probably a one-to-one meetings
with various cabinet ministers about the
progress their departments are making in
tackling coronavirus starting almost
certainly with Matt Hancock the health
secretary this evening he's likely to be
talking to his closest aides prior to
those meetings with ministers we may see
some ministers going into number 10 this
evening although the pre M may be
ordered by his doctors to get an early
night tonight and start their big
meetings tomorrow so top of the entry
this debate raging about when and
whether and how to ease the lockdown
also he'll want to talk to mr. Hancock
about testing and the health Secretary's
ambitious pledge which some doubt can be
achieved of a hundred thousand
coronavirus tests a day by the end of
April which is Thursday just a few days
away now but there is this huge debate
as we've heard from ministers like
Dominic Robb on Sky News today George
Eustace at the news conference this
evening about the about the lockdown
today Tory donors have joined the calls
for easing of the lockdown and yet some
scientists have said it could be as many
as a hundred thousand deaths if it's
relaxed too soon so that is the acute
dilemma facing the prime minister back
in Downing Street back at work
officially tomorrow and headlong into a
big agenda it's possible we may well see
him at the news conference tomorrow at
five o'clock
George Eustace the Environment Secretary
did say a couple of hours ago we would
be seeing him this week yeah you say it
is an acute dilemma and of course that's
exactly what it is trying to work out
what the exit strategy is to all of this
the government at the moment saying no
change to the lockdown but have there
been any hints at all John about what
potential tweaks could be coming in the
next few weeks well we've learned this
weekend that on Friday the PM had a big
meeting three hours by all accounts with
mr. Rob is stand in for the past
fortnight and crucially Rishi's soon act
the Chancellor at Chequers they were
joined by a video conference call video
linked by the cabinet secretary Dominic
Cummings and possibly a few other aides
as well to discuss where the government
is on this now I'm told that mr. su naka
outlined some of the measures being
taken in other countries like for
example allowing more shops to open
changing employees working patterns
staggering them so more people can get
back to work without breaching the
social distancing guidelines the big
debate of course that is affecting so
many families as well as the pol
additions the reopening of schools lot
of opinions on that for and against
other issues let Tory MPs of today been
talking about anomalies in the current
rules garden centers calls for garden
centers to reopen and calls for markets
and so on to reopen as well as smaller
shops now mr. Robb talks about a Phase
two today he also talked about a new
normal
a phrase also used by Nicola Sturgeon
the Scotland Scotland's first minister
mr. mr. Eustace talks about the next
stage so clearly ministers are
discussing the next stage phase two
whatever you like to call it there is
talk that the slogan will change stay at
home protect the NHS save lives adapt a
different slogan perhaps as there is a
change even if it's only a nuanced one
it's like tweaking of the rules and then
in the next phase so the next week or so
is crucial because they've been claims
that no effective decisions have been
taken in the Prime Minister's absence
mr. Robb really has didn't mean doing
little more than sharing meetings and of
course appearing at the news conferences
but of course the number-10 have already
talked about the Prime Minister getting
a grip on the process with his return
and I'm pretty sure we will see the mr.
Johnson possibly at tomorrow's news
conference